nc-17 first of all the name don't ask
about it it's a little late
[Music]
how do you feel about it I mean I'm so
excited it just keeps getting added on
and I don't want to stop because it
means so much to me that I'm being able
to put this album out like I'm sorry
it's running late but it's just it's
been such like it's like a baby you know
they like my little project that I've
been working on for such a long time and
I've been like holding it in for such a
long time that I'm I'm open to waiting a
little longer to get it just the way I
wanted it come out
[Music]
the music's been part of your life your
family and music now for yourself how
does that feel for you is it your own is
a euro reflection of who you are yeah
absolutely I think I mean I started
writing music when I was 15 in the
studio and only one producer wanted to
work with me name is Jason - Suzy oh
he's doing massive hits right now
Thunder with imagine dragons
I have a full basically album with him
that I never heard out from when I was
15 and so I've always wanted my music to
reflect on Who I am and I've always
wanted to be really upfront with my fans
you know what I mean who are you I'm a
mess I mean I just I just want them to
know that like you know I'm not just a
figure doing music like I am a real
eighteen year old that you know wakes up
in the morning the same way that they do
and I get ready the same way they do and
go through my day the same way that they
do I just might be doing something a
little different
[Music]
you were on tour with Katy Perry that
experience for you how was it that was
wild I'm incredibly grateful for that
and like for Katy to like take a
brand-new artist so it's only been out a
year on to her tour I think was really
cool of her and like totally like a big
chance for me she was so talented at
such a young age and she wanted it so
bad I think she understands what it's
like to be a new artist you know what I
mean and I'm from her like documentary
she put out a long time ago I remember
watching on being like that is so sick
like you know she started from like solo
and like totally just built herself up
and created this entire career for
herself so I really look up to her as an
artist she'd give you any advice why you
guys weren't worried I think from
watching her that was like the best
advice she could have given me is just
watching her every night and watching
her confidence grow like first show to
my last show on that run but started off
like there would be like production
errors and getting how she handled that
was so beautiful and like so graceful
and she just she pulled it off so well
are you talking about being on stage and
being in front of your fans and they're
singing your songs that must have an
amazing influence on you as a new artist
it's really incredible and like my
favorite thing about being a new artist
is you know it's kind of difficult in a
way to go out in front of a crowd that
doesn't know you and you can tell that
they don't know you in a way and like as
you get your energy up and as you start
to connect with people that don't know
you you can see them catch on and you
know when they start engaging with your
music and that's probably the most
beautiful thing to see I love you and I
can't wait for years thank you so much